Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show, where it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers across many, many disciplines.
My guest today, I'm so happy to have him,
is Bill Gurley.
You can find him on Twitter @bgurley.
That's G-U-R-L-E-Y.
Bill has spent more than 20 years as a general
partner at Benchmark.
Before entering the venture capital business,
Bill spent four years on Wall Street as a
top ranked research analyst, including three
years at Credit — got a little Elmer Fudd,
hold on, including three years at Credit Suisse
First Boston.
Bill also maintains a blog on the evolution
and economics of high-technology businesses
called Above the Crowd, which you can find
at abovethecrowd.com.
Over his venture career, he has worked with
such companies as GrubHub, Next door, OpenTable,
Stitch Fix, Uber and Zillow among many others.
Bill has BS in computer science from the University
of Florida and an MBA from the University
of Texas.
He's also chartered financial analyst.
Bill is a board trustee at the Santa Fe Institute,
a research and education center focused on
the study and understanding of complex adaptive
systems.
Bill, nice to see you.
Thanks for making the time.
Bill Gurley: Thanks for having me.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so I wanted to start
with a number of things that I've seen pop
up repeatedly in various forms in doing prep
for this conversation.
And the first I wanted to get your take on
and expansion on is Michael Porter's book
Competitive Strategy: Techniques for Analyzing
Industries and Competitors, which you have
described I believe as the most efficient
short-form MBA that one can find.
Could you please explain what this book is
and if you still hold that opinion, why you
hold that opinion?
Bill Gurley: If you do go to get an MBA like
in the first semester or whatever, they usually
make you take a corporate strategy course
and it's the first book assigned.
It's like extremely well known business book.
There's a belief in Silicon Valley that an
MBA's worthless and that people shit on it
all the time.
Yet, I would say 80 percent or 90 percent
of the entrepreneurs I meet would benefit
greatly by reading the first three chapters
of this book.
And it's really just about trying to understand
the dynamics of industry.
One of the most common mistakes entrepreneurs
make is they come up with some kind of technological
breakthrough in their own mind, but they don't
spend any time analyzing the industry structure
or whether the go-to market is going to be
possible or not.
And the book just has a wonderful framework
for thinking about the competitive dynamics
of an industry and whether or not you'd be
able to break in or be successful or maintain
success.
Tim Ferriss: Well, this actually makes me
think more broadly of frameworks and recipes
as it were for making decisions.
So back in the day, you were a sell-side analyst
and I would love for you to define what that
is and also just define buy-side versus sell-side.
And at that time, at one point at least, "...the
top three analysts covering the PC industry
retired…"
And I'm reading from a transcript on Medium,
"...Dan Benton, David Korus…" if I'm pronouncing
that —
Bill Gurley: That's correct.
Tim Ferriss: "…and Charlie Wolf…" and
then "...Charlie became the advisor for young
analysts…"
so you got to work with him.
Here's the part that's of interest to me.
So "Dan and David became friends, so they
both gave me all their [financial] models."
And I'm curious what they gave you.
What were those models?
And do you still use any of those models?
Bill Gurley: No, no, no.
So to be specific, but let me start with the
sell versus buy.
So and the industry's changed over the years,
but a sell-side analyst is someone who does
research on behalf of an investment bank that
is presumably going to make money from trading
on their trading desk that someone sends your
way because they valued the research.
So you're providing research to help sell
stocks.
That's how you're going to get paid.
The buy-side is anyone at a mutual fund who's
trading for their own account.
So if you're a buy-side analyst, you don't
publish.
It doesn't get public because you're using
that as proprietary information.
The sell-side stuff gets broadcast broadly.
And usually when someone changes estimates
or you hear about a ratings change, that's
usually a sell-side analyst that has made
a decision to change something.
And that's what ends up on CNBC.
Tim Ferriss: And so a sell-side analyst, this
is going to sound very naive, but a sell-side
analyst could make a recommendation to buy,
right?
They could make a recommendation like a strong
buy recommendation or a strong sell or somewhere
in between the two.
That's I think where my Long Island brain
was having trouble grasping the basics.
Bill Gurley: There's a controversy about that
because the bank makes money in multiple ways
and they question whether people are biased
or not.
And then you had the whole Henry Blodget thing
from the 2000 period.
So it's complicated.
Tim Ferriss: And could you describe, I know
that you don't at this point use them any
longer, but the company-specific models, what
were the models [inaudible]?
Bill Gurley: I was super fortunate my entire
career by being in places where windows opened
up that I was able to take advantage of.
But the situation you described, I landed
on Wall Street very fortunately, started covering
an industry, and there's a magazine called
Institutional Investor that pulls the buy-side
and ranks the analyst and the top three analyst
in the category I entered all retired within
one year.
And they all became friends partially from
my own networking, like I was reaching out
to them, but the models they shared were the
models they had built on the companies we
all covered.
So their own particular version of Dell Financials
or Compaq or Microsoft.
And so it just helped me have a better understanding.
I could see what they did, that kind of thing.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
So what I'm trying to unpack also through
the course of this conversation is just how
you think about models and making decisions.
I find that interesting.
So this is hopping around a little bit, but
you did not pursue Google as an investment
in 2002 and you had some investing rules of
thumb in place.
And I suppose what I'm wondering is how you
think about rules as an investor in the sense
that it seems like perhaps to be consistently
great you need rules, but if you have rules,
you're inevitably going to miss some great
opportunities.
But perhaps that's okay.
How do you think about rules?
Was missing Google the result of a flaw in
the set of rules that you had at the time?
Or was it just sort of a collateral miss that
was —
Bill Gurley: Well, let me work my way back
to it because it's clearly the biggest mistake
of my career.
So I thought about it a lot.
So I think any investor starts with just building
bedrock and that comes from reading.
And there's a ton of books in history.
You can go through all the Buffett letters
as an example.
You can read Peter Lynch's One Up On Wall
Street.
There's my good friend Mike Mauboussin who
has put out some amazing books that are a
lot more nuanced about stock prices, that
kind of thing.
A Random Walk Down Wall Street by Burton Malkiel.
And then you build your bedrock and then you're
out there and you're looking for an opportunity.
So I think public stocks are a little different
than venture, but there's some overlap.
But you're looking for a reality that you
think is going to emerge.
It's not priced into the stock.
So that requires you both to know or to think
you know where the world's going.
And also to know what the expectations are
currently embedded in the stock because if
you just have the same opinion that's already
embedded, you're not going to make any money.
There's a great piece by Howard Marks where
he talks about you have to be right and contrarian.
Yeah, you can't just be right.
You have to be right and contrarian, and that's
more difficult.
There's a famous saying that I'm sure it's
been uttered on your podcast before, but kind
of strong opinions, loosely held.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Bill Gurley: I think all investors have to
work within that framework because things
change.
There's many, many variables.
None of them are constant, they're all dynamic.
And the minute you set a very hard rule, then
you might be setting yourself up for a mistake.
And venture, I have found, is a world where
that happens frequently.
And so the Google example, and it's really
important to say that we didn't lay chase.
There were 25 employees Larry and Sergey presented,
they presented to I'm sure a whole bunch of
firms.
And we didn't lay chase.
We should have laid chase, but we didn't.
At the time, Yahoo was at $10 down from, like,
80.
Excite was going bankrupt.
So search didn't look that exciting from an
external viewpoint.
You had two PhD founders who had never been
a CEO before and were insistent they were
going to be good as a CEO.
Normally that's a red flag.
Yeah, PhD founders.
And there was just a number of things where
you would make a list and say, "Oops, this
probably isn't what you want to do."
Now I'd like to highlight, and I always do,
the two best venture capitalists in the world
at the time, John Doerr, Mike Moritz kind
of locked hands and said yes.
And so it'd be erroneous for me to say, "Oh,
if you were a well-studied venture catalyst,
you obviously get to know at that point in
time because the two bests didn't."
And I think it's just the subtlety of the
game.
There's a great reality in venture that a
lot of people talk about now, but you can
only lose one time your money.
And in a case like Google, you make, what?
10,000 times your money.
And that asymmetric result means you have
to bias towards positive in a situation like
that because the odds are just ridiculously
different.
So what should have happened is I remember
one of my partners looking at Larry and saying,
"What does it take to get this deal done right
now?"
Because he was a closer tie and Larry said
"120 pre."
And we should have said, "How about 150?"
If I could go back, but you can't go back.
Deal got done at 80.
So below what Larry had told us, but still
obviously historic.
Tim Ferriss: So how did you then revise your
rules of thumb or rules moving forward after
that, if at all?
Is a case like that granted it turned into
what Google is now, so it's easy to maybe
punish yourself for not laying chase.
But how did things change after that?
Bill Gurley: After that, the firm did Twitter,
Snapchat, Uber, we got some right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you did.
Bill Gurley: And around that time I remember
we used to give a book out to our LPs, our
limited partners, our investors at every annual
meeting.
And I think Bruce had just read The Rational
Optimist, which is a Matt Ridley book.
And he started using a phrase at our partner
meeting, "What could go right?"
And because of this asymmetric outcome thing
where you could make 10,000 times your money
and only lose once on the downside, it was
the right frame of mind.
So it's very easy to get into a trap in venture
where getting no right feels like a win.
And it's just not that, I mean obviously you
can't do every deal, you can't do every investment,
you go broke.
But getting overly jazzed about correctly
identifying a negative or a no, it's just
not that big a deal.
It's not the job.
The job is to find the outliers.
Tim Ferriss: So my experience, granted it's
limited in some respects, my experience and
perception of Benchmark 'cause you guys are
very, very selective more, let me rephrase
that, more selective than a lot of venture
capital firms and a lot of angels who, maybe
like the poker player who doesn't mind his
or her bank roll, yes, you can only use 1X
your money, but if you do lose all of your
money, the jig is up, right?
Bill Gurley: That's the problem with the complete
opposite theory.
You can't just do every investment you meet.
And we have another challenge, Tim, which
is we've for a variety of reasons have chosen
a strategy where we don't let our money walk
around without our work product and our involvement.
And so we go on a board if we make an investment
and we usually become the largest shareholder
on the board.
And as a result, our limitation is our board
seats more than the capital actually.
Tim Ferriss: It's a tie.
Bill Gurley: You can't do 20 of them, like
not well.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So you mentioned Howard Marks, Oaktree Capital,
who's been on the podcast twice.
Very, very impressive fellow.
So I've seen you mention two investors, I'm
sure you've mentioned more, but two have come
up repeatedly in various interviews and so
on.
Howard Marks and Stan Druckenmiller.
Could you please speak to what makes them
impressive or interesting to you?
Bill Gurley: Some time in the last four or
five years when interest rates wouldn't get
away from zero for so long, I told myself
I have to learn more about macro because I
just know nothing and it's causing all kind
of problems in my industry.
I had been reading Howard's work for years.
One of the things I just love about people
like Howard and Buffett does it, but people
who archive their thought process just as
part of their own process.
But it's quite kind if you're a learner in
the field, to have someone of that capability
that insists upon writing these letters and
making them public, which they've done.
So I started reading Howard's work when I
was on the sell-side 25 years ago and I've
gotten to know him now and in addition to
being very, very bright, he's also just a
wonderful human and fun to interact with.
There aren't many people, if you study financial
history, most people in Buffett included will
tell you, "Macro is impossible.
You shouldn't even try."
And the two individuals you mentioned are
two of the only ones that are known for being
successful in macro investing.
Howard mostly by being one of the most successful
and longest tenured investor in the bond market
and Stan for taking more kind of single individual
bets that are macro in nature going back to
his success with Soros, he's become re-famous
in the past 12 months for predicting the inflation
situation we're in and being very loud about
it.
Tim Ferriss: If you don't mind, just give
a definition — it could be simple — of
macro investing for people who may not know
that term.
Bill Gurley: Macro, if you go to business
school, the there's two economic class you
can take: microeconomics and macroeconomics.
Microeconomics is a lot about what's discussed
in competitive strategy, the Michael Porter
book.
So it's about the interaction between firms
within an industry pricing, that kind of thing,
competitive dynamics.
Macro is the study of economies writ large.
And I'm fascinated with complex systems.
Our economy is certainly one of those things
as is weather and whatnot, which is why I've
gotten involved with the Santa Fe Institute.
But they're nearly impossible to predict.
And it's where you get into real, real trouble.
There might be a variable you're not tracking
that has never flipped from zero to one.
And when it does flip from zero to one, all
your models, all your planning are out the
window because this other thing's different
this time.
I mean it's why no one can predict the weather
more than five days in front of us because
it is just too dynamic and too complex.
And most people feel that way about macro.
Tim Ferriss: Let me go back in time a little
bit, revisiting the sell-side analyst side
of things.
So I believe at one point, and I could be
getting the terminology wrong, but you are
an Institutional Investor, which you already
mentioned Institutional Investor, All-American
— or All-America — Research Team –
Bill Gurley: Partly because there's three
people that left the field, but yes.
Tim Ferriss: So what allows someone to land
on that list?
How do they choose the people?
Bill Gurley: So it's a poll of your customers.
It's a poll of the buy-side.
So they literally poll the buy-side in each
industry and say, "Who was most helpful?"
I will tell you that, and I don't know, this
probably came from some book I read in business
school, but when I showed up, and this is
a framework someone could use.
But when I showed up on Wall Street in one
of the very first weekly meetings, they introduced
us to the sales force.
The sales force is the individual at your
firm responsible for that account, for Fidelity,
for Wellington, for Teachers of Texas, or
whatever.
And they own the relationship.
And somewhere in my youthful wisdom, I decided
to ask each salesperson, is there one client
that will spend 30 to 45 minutes with me as
a new analyst and just tell me what they want.
I'm just going to ask them questions.
I'm not going to have anything for them.
I just want to know how I can serve them best.
And I did 20 of those interviews before I
had started the job.
And that's a roundabout answer to how do you
get on the list because I knew what they were
looking for at that point.
Tim Ferriss: So what made you a good analyst?
And let me explain why I'm asking.
I'm asking because one of the advantages that
you bring to a board, which you've already
discussed to a board of a startup in the art
of company building is your in-depth understanding
of how the public markets work and if a company
is aiming for going public and so on, you
have knowledge that intimidates or befuddles
a lot of folks who might otherwise want to
be on the board.
So I'm curious to know what made you a good
analyst?
Bill Gurley: The thing I learned in those
interviews, both in terms of the — because
I would also ask him, "Who does a really good
job of this?"
And then if I could, I'd try and befriend
that person.
But what I heard frequently back was, look,
and this is a little different from what the
world perceives, "I don't really need you
to make this buy or sell recommendation.
What I would really get a huge benefit from
is if you provide a point of view or a piece
of analysis that causes us to think differently
about a particular company or industry.
And you go off and do some work that other
people haven't thought of that causes us to
question that makes us want to talk to you
and hear what you're thinking."
And so that became really the essence of what
I was focused on and partially from listening
to them and partially from mimicking and copying
David Korus, who you mentioned, I started
doing a weekly fax at the time and David was
doing that before he quit.
And so I started doing it too.
And interestingly, the Wall Street firm tries
to keep your content closed within their customer
set.
And this is not very loyal to my firm, but
it became very obvious to me that a sell-side
analyst that was more well known was more
powerful, more impactful.
And so I intentionally started expanding the
distribution of this weekly pieces as far
and wide as I could.
Tim Ferriss: How did you expand that distribution?
Bill Gurley: I would leverage the sales force
and get them to give me fax numbers.
That's that's where I started.
I then started developing industry relationships,
which is important because you're covering
these companies, you start going to investor
days.
The buy-side is talking to these companies
as well.
And so I started getting some of them on board.
And then probably the most successful hack
of my career happened when I was invited to
attend Stewart Alsop’s Agenda conference,
which I think was in Phoenix at the time.
And used to be, it was the conference everyone
went to.
So Gates would be in the front row, Ellison
would be there.
They would stay for the whole thing.
You could walk up and talk to them.
Michael Dell was there.
Everyone was there.
Tim Ferriss: How many analysts were invited
to such an event?
Bill Gurley: I don't know.
Charlie had been invited and Charlie got me
in and I don't even remember.
Rick Sherlund was probably there.
He's a famous Microsoft analyst and it's kind
of what code is today.
But the difference way back then was the most
famous founder CEOs sat through the whole
thing and were available the whole time.
Today, if one of them speaking, they come
in the back door, they go on stage, they leave.
They're not around.
So it was pretty cool.
Tim Ferriss: And what was the hack at the
conference?
Bill Gurley: So this was around the time where
the Palm Pilot launched.
And so in the lobby of the conference was
they were selling them.
They weren't free, they were selling them,
selling a Palm pilot.
And I think it was like $200, $300, I can't
remember.
But they had put the contact information for
every attendee at the conference in the Palm
Pilot.
So I ran some quick math.
People weren't really doing cost of customer
acquisition back then, but I think it was
like 70 cents a name or something like that
of the most influential people in the entire
tech industry.
And so I bought the Palm Pilot, I took it
home, and I spammed the 400 or 500 most important
people in the tech industry with my weekly
newsletter.
Tim Ferriss: Did you end up developing close
or closer relationships with any of them because
of that newsletter?
Bill Gurley: I think so.
And I think also just a reputation and if
the content you produce is — I mean it's
actually not that surprising today.
There's plenty of content influencers all
over the place now with Substack and everything.
It was just a version of that when there weren't
as many people doing it.
And it started with fax and became email.
And today I just mostly tweeted.
I don't force the distribution out of these
other things anymore and I'm not as frequent.
But yeah, I mean it's a common way to build
reputation in a network and I mean you do
this with your own line, so.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do.
I do.
So let's come back to the point you made of
helping your clients think differently, right?
Yeah.
Presenting them with something that helps
them to think differently.
And I'd like to connect that to a story I'd
love you to tell, which is about what you
learned from a food analyst.
And the question that might come before that
is how did you meet the food analyst?
Why were you even having a conversation?
Bill Gurley: Yeah, so when I arrived at — well,
first of all, the analysts share a floor.
So we're all physically proximate.
So the person that covers food or telcos or
electric utilities, we're all in the same
group.
And the firm had efforts underway, which Charlie
Wolf ended up running to try and educate the
analyst in a common framework or whatever
so that we would all be better at what we
do and that kind of thing.
And I mean, I guess birds of a feather flock
together for reasons I don't remember, me
and Michael J. Mauboussin, the food analyst,
started spending a lot of time together and
we're still close friends today.
He's involved at Santa Fe and I'd see him
frequently and he's done amazing things himself
and released several books and he's quite
well known.
So we started hanging out together.
He had just read a bunch of books on a framework
called Return On Invested Capital, which Stern
Stewart had published on.
McKinsey had a book called Valuation, they
still do, that uses this type of analysis.
And he was spreading it.
It was the word proselytizing through the
analyst group.
And I was a sponge at that point in time.
So I say sure.
So I took the framework and ran it on all
of my companies.
It turned out just by happenstance that Dell
stood out like a sore thumb with ridiculously
high ROIC numbers versus the rest of the industry.
Like night and day, like 20 to one, wasn't
even close.
And in fact, it was so ridiculous the first
time I showed him, Michael didn't believe
it was true.
And so we got in the numbers and that kind
of thing.
There's probably 10 super lucky things that
happened in my life, but him giving me that
framework and then at the exact same time,
Dell as a company had made two stumbles.
They had an options trade that went bad and
their laptops had caught on fire.
And so the stock was in the ditch.
It was trading at six times earnings.
And we had discovered, if you will, through
this framework that they had a massive competitive
advantage because of this return on invested
capital thing.
And so we went to a strong buy on a broken
stock and it went up 100X in the public markets
from there.
And I became close friends with Michael and
Tom Meredith, who was CFO at the time.
They did all the work.
I was just along for the ride, but it was
very fortunate.
Tim Ferriss: That helped put Bill Gurley on
the map in the same way that maybe eBay really
thrust Benchmark into the limelight.
Bill Gurley: Very much so, very much so.
Especially with the buy-side community.
Tim Ferriss: So Michael, I just wanted to
double-check this.
There's a chance I've read a book of his.
Did he write a book called Think Twice: Harnessing
the Power of Counterintuition, or is that
a different Michael?
Bill Gurley: He's written four or five books
and he's, he's got great content.
He did a Google Talk that's on YouTube that
I'd highly recommend people watch.
It's just fascinating.
He's been on O'Shaughnessy a couple times,
so yeah, he's worth checking out.
Tim Ferriss: So in that particular case of
proselytizing, did Michael do that?
Was he proselytizing and sharing this ROIC
idea because he had peers who were non-competitive
and is sort of a deposit in the karmic bank
account to hopefully have some reciprocation?
Or is he just a nice guy?
It just seems like the environment, that would
not be true in all environments, right?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: That someone would take this
new insight and share it widely.
Bill Gurley: I think he's a natural learner,
and maybe that's what you would attribute
Howard Marks' writing to.
You ask people who do that, when you ask Buffett,
"Why do you write your letters?"
I think people believe that it helps their
mental frameworks if they write stuff down,
and it challenges them.
Even when I write a blog post, from the minute
I have an idea or a compulsion to say, "Hey,
I'm going to write about this topic," the
process through which you actually put the
words to paper and structure the paragraphs,
structure the argument, you get smarter.
Sometimes you decide, "Oops, I was wrong."
You learn by putting it all together.
And Michael's always been that way.
He's pretty much built a career out of being
someone who studies companies, valuation frameworks,
how investors win.
I mean, he's gone deep on things like Myers-Briggs
on different investors and structural, how
do you organize an investment team to be most
— all kinds of stuff like that.
And it's what fascinates him, and he's a synthesizer.
And I think some of the best non-fiction writers
are synthesizers.
People say, "Oh, Michael Porter, Competitive
Strategy," 14 other people had written that
stuff before.
Well, he wrote it in a really compact way
that's easy to read.
That's super helpful.
And Michael does that with — he goes out
and reads the stuff that's super hard to read,
that's overly academic or whatnot, and packages
in a way that people can consume.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I remember Kevin Kelly said to me once, and
I'm paraphrasing, but I really enjoy Kevin
Kelly.
For people who don't know, look him up, KK.org,
and he was saying, "I don't write to express
what I think.
I write in order to think or discover what
I think or clarify what I think."
So the taking of the ROIC from, in this case,
let's just say food and applying it to Dell,
was this sort of translational move.
So I want to read something from, I think
this was a Vox interview, and you can't believe
everything you read on the internet, but it
would make sense.
So this is related to OpenTable.
So, "Having come out of OpenTable being successful,"
this is quoting you, "I was trying to think
of other industries where, if you put a network
on top of [it, that] would absorb waste and
make it more efficient and more usable."
And this is within the context of looking
for something that would basically appear
like Uber.
So not working within the taxi framework but
with black cars.
And I'm just curious where else you've applied
that type of translation where you see a case
study or a successful proof of a network being
laid on top of something and then applying
it to something else.
Are there other examples of translating in
that way?
Bill Gurley: Absolutely.
And by the way, OpenTable was built on top.
Our impetus to do OpenTable was based upon
something like that.
So in 1996, Brian Arthur, who was at the Santa
Fe Institute back then, published an article
in Harvard Business Review called “Increasing
Returns and the Two Worlds of Business.”
And it was really the first piece that talked
about network effects.
Of course, Microsoft was already starting
to really take off, but this idea of network
effects is that some industries are going
to be structured where you get win or take
most, and the more successful you are, you
get locked in.
And Brian talked about things just like the
Microsoft UIs.
You know how Word works, you get comfortable
with how it works, and then switching has
cost and those kind of things, and sharing
documents and collaboration.
And Zoom obviously has massive network effects.
So we started looking for those things because
they tend to cause outlier outcomes.
So I can remember, and this gets into back
to your rule stuff, when I met with Chuck
Templeton, the founder of OpenTable, and he
had three restaurants.
You had to believe a lot to get from that
point to the global phenomenon that it became.
And the bet that we talked about making when
we said, "Okay, let's go do this thing," is
"If we get enough restaurants on this thing,
then the consumers will come.
And if the consumers come, then people will
have to get on."
And that's what happened.
But you had to believe it because otherwise,
at the time, we were selling PCs to restaurant
owners, and guess what?
They didn't have connectivity at the time.
So we had to partner with someone to get broadband
installed, which wasn't easy.
I mean, it was all bad.
So your normal work set, we're putting a piece
of hardware in a small to medium business
that didn't have a lot of money, and we had
to provision broadband.
So you would normally go, "Don't do that."
But I remember my favorite proof point of
that network effect, and then I'll get to
some of the other models.
At one point we were reviewing the sales force
productivity, and our model when we scaled
up the business that we had or each salesperson
had to close four restaurants a month.
And at the time we were up to 7.7, so we were
feeling pretty good.
Things were starting to break our way.
And in the board meeting, they laid out the
list of all the salespeople, and one of them
had done 35, 35 restaurants in a month.
And so I asked the question, "Who is that
salesperson?"
And OpenTable started in San Francisco, and
we played local game.
We didn't go everywhere at once.
We built liquidity city by city.
Anyway, at the time, that salesperson was
the one salesperson left in San Francisco
where we had 90 percent penetration.
And so the 35 were coming out of that last
10.
And that individual was basically taking orders.
And that to me was like, "Oh, yeah, the network
effects really working here."
So anyway, we look for that.
Some other frameworks, SaaS.
Tim Ferriss: Could I actually pause for one
second before you get to SaaS?
So you talked about you have to believe, you
mentioned you have to believe a lot of things
can go right in order to invest in a business
like OpenTable at the time.
So now I would love to know what contributed
to your ability to have conviction?
I mean, how much of it was potential network
effects versus total addressable market versus
founder versus other stuff?
Bill Gurley: Oh, I mean, I would say in some
of these verticals, both OpenTable and Uber,
there were years and years and years where
everyone thought the TAM was too small.
In fact, oh, here's a great story.
So this was in '99, so this is a 23-year-old
story, but I had successfully recruited a
CFO from a public company, which you could
do back in those glory days to come into OpenTable.
And one day I showed up early for a board
meeting, and the CFO comes to me and he says,
"Bill, I'm going to quit."
And I said, "Okay."
I go, "Why are you going to quit?"
And he goes, "This business will never work."
And I said, "Okay, why will it never work?"
And he says, "Well, my model says it'll never
work."
So I said, "Show me your model."
So we look at the model and I dive in, and
he has frozen penetration in each city at
17 percent.
And he had come from a retail business.
And I go, "Why'd you freeze it at 17 percent?"
And he said, "Oh, no one gets more than 17
percent market share, all the businesses I've
worked with."
And because I believed in network effects,
I was like, "We're going to get 99.
We're not stopping at 17, we're going to get
99 percent.
You don't understand how this is going to
work."
And that's because I believed in network effects
and he didn't.
When we filed the S-1, I really wanted to
FedEx it.
Tim Ferriss: Did he stay or did he leave?
Bill Gurley: No, he left.
He quit, and I decided not to FedEx in the
S-1.
I figured he had seen, but by then we were
kicking off massive cash flow.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Bill Gurley: It's cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So you're talking about models, and I interrupted
you.
You were going to jump to SaaS.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, I was just going to mention
a bunch of them.
I mean —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, please.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
So I did my first SaaS deal in '99, and that
category of companies is still bearing fruit.
People have made tons of money, and now it's
common but at the time it wasn't.
And you transformed an entire industry, open
source, Benchmark probably had, I don't know,
eight or nine successful open source companies
where you've used that model to attack an
industry that's preexisting, but where someone
has proprietary technology.
Social networks, I mean, we were fortunate
to be in Twitter, Snapchat, Instagram, and
Matt Cohler, who was a partner at Benchmark,
developed kind of a sixth sense on what a
breakout social network looks like.
And we've had a few that missed too, but the
outsized nature of the winds are so high.
So there's like four or five different ones
that we look for, network effects, open source,
and you get good at it.
You start to understand what works, what doesn't,
what leads to success, what doesn't.
I mean, there's nuances.
In open source, with that business model,
which is you're basically packaging support
and reliability, because someone could just
download it for free so how do you charge?
And this goes back to Michael Porter, but
if you have a very consolidated industry of
big companies, they don't pay.
They just hire the people that know how to
use the product.
MySQL is an example.
Google and Yahoo were two of the biggest customers,
never paid us a penny.
You need that product to go into the corporate
world where people want that kind of handholding,
and that's where you get paid.
So you can't just be, "Oh, I love open source,"
because then you get into something where
it's serving a much more finite set of customers,
and then you can't make the model work.
So you have to learn the esoteric nuances.
But anyway, yeah, there are many veins and
venture that get mined over and over and over
again if they're big enough.
Tim Ferriss: And this is maybe a novice question,
but I'm curious, what rules did you guys have
around bet sizing?
To use maybe a poker analogy.
How do you think about the parameters around
the size of the check that you cut?
Just in terms of long-term strategy.
Bill Gurley: Benchmark's a very particular
firm, and we've stayed — we've wandered
off course a couple times, but we've always
come back to our kind of home base.
And we've remained committed and focused to
very early stage investing, and we're pretty
much market takers on what that first check
size is.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by that?
Bill Gurley: I mean, there's a competitive
dynamic in the industry that kind of defines
what a series A check looks like or sometimes
series B. If we thought something was going
to be an outsized winner, we wouldn't miss
it because market was saying that had to be
15 or five.
It's more like a ticket.
Like refining —
Tim Ferriss: 15 or five, you're talking about
15 or five million, right?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So would the guiding principle
in a case that be the percentage of ownership
that you would end up with?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Much more, something we care way more about
than the size of the check.
Yeah, yeah.
And we're not the only one.
A lot of venture firms operate that way.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, sure.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
So board seat is the constraint, and then
ownership is the optimization variable, whatever
the math is that follows out of that is what
you take.
Tim Ferriss: So to be right and contrarian,
I mean, I guess sometimes in venture, I'm
not sure if it — I mean, I'm curious how
you cultivate that in partner meetings.
What is the format of a successful partner
meeting when someone's getting up and saying,
"Here's my deal."
Bill Gurley: Well, one thing I would offer
as a preamble to at least our process is the
founding partners of Benchmark did something
that hadn't been done before in venture, which
is they created an equal partnership.
And most business partnerships, and this includes
private equity and law firms and real estate
firms, there's a hierarchy.
And the people that have been there the longest
sit at the very top, and they take an outsized
amount.
And some of our founding partners had worked
at those firms and felt like the young people
did more of the work, and therefore it wasn't
conducive to the right type of internal behavior.
And so they created this notion of an equal
partnership.
And even today when we go hire a new partner,
they come in and they have an equal seat at
the table.
We just divide the pie, which is very different.
The reason I think that's important to any
discussion about our own processes is I think
that has a number of dynamics that kind of
emerge from being equal.
I think everyone's voice is heard, whereas
if you had a hierarchical firm and big boss
walked in and said, "Blah, blah, blah," that
was carry still much more weight, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Bill Gurley: And so you feel like your voice
is heard when you come in.
I think we root for one another.
So if I'm at a hierarchical firm that's up
or out, I'm kind of competing with my peers
here because we're going to divide it equally.
I want our new partners to be as successful
as they possibly can, and I felt that on the
way in, and I feel the desire to do it on
the way out.
And those are just natural emergent properties.
And the answer, so then to come around to
your question, how do you be contrarian?
How do you have — well, I mentioned we have
this phrase, "What could go right?"
You're just constantly thinking devil's advocate
in your mind and devil's advocate on the positive
side, like what would it take for this thing
to break out?
Are we making a mistake?
Could you imagine this being really, really
big?
And what would have to happen for that to
happen.
When someone new comes along, you'd be surprised.
I have specific memories of new partners coming
in, and we'll just tell them, "Bring all the
companies you meet in.
Just bring them in."
And those companies will present, and then
we talk about them afterwards, and that's
—
Tim Ferriss: Into the partner meeting?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
And that's where the learning process gets
passed down.
I'm sure just like storytelling in a tribe
300 years ago or 400 years ago, right?
That is that dynamic.
And it's weird.
A lot of people say venture is at the end
of the day, a pattern recognition job, but
we also talked about those rules can get you
in trouble.
So you're trying to create these kind of loose
pattern recognition so that you can be helpful
and identify things, and then you want to
pass those along.
And then you got to constantly check it because
of what we said about how you could miss something.
But when that new partner comes in and those
are happening, I can remember, and I'll leave
the names out, but one of the new partners,
he brought in company one, "No," company two,
"No."
He was very frustrated.
And then company 10 he brought in, and we
were like, "Try and close that immediately,"
just the complete opposite.
And he remembers that too.
But you're starting to learn, you're starting
to pick up the collective wisdom of the group.
And it is a bit of an art form because in
that window between when you meet a company
and when you might try and close the investment,
I bet you the average is under 60 days.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For sure.
Bill Gurley: It might even be closer to three
weeks.
And so it all happened super fast.
Tim Ferriss: Was there any feedback that you
recall or could just hypothetically imagine
you gave that new partner that helped him
or her to hone in on the 10th that was then
a "Yes, close this immediately?"
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
But I mean, a lot of it goes back to what
you might pick up in competitive strategy.
The two books that I would put for the venture
community, for the startup community that
I would put as next level right on top of
Competitive Strategy or Innovator's Dilemma,
which does an amazing job of describing why
startups can compete with big companies.
Amazing.
And Crossing the Chasm, which does a really
good job of explaining how a startup should
kind of sequence their customer base as they
grow.
And they're both fundamental.
And you just pick up a number of these different
things, and I'll give you an example because
you start to develop intuition.
So a company where we had a quick yes on that
I'm on the board of is called HackerOne.
So at the time of HackerOne's founding, there
were four companies that used white hat hackers
to make their sites more secure.
Microsoft, Google, Facebook, and Mozilla,
they were the only four.
No one else did it.
And yet people would say, I remember seeing
an interview with Sheryl Sandberg where she
said, someone asked her about privacy and
security, and she says, "Well, the best thing
we have is this bug bounty program."
And she talks about it for a while and the
crowd applauds.
And so one of the individuals that worked
on the Facebook program came up with a business
idea of, "Why don't we build this for the
other companies in the universe, like every
other company in the universe?"
And when they presented, we didn't even discuss
the company.
The minute they left, we were like, "Okay,
how are we going to close this?"
Everyone had just jumped to "Yes," because
it seemed so tautological, that there's no
way this thing's great for these four companies
and no one else.
And it turned out that those four companies
had a group of 20 or 30 people running the
program, which other companies couldn't do.
So it was just natural that if you ran that
as a service, people would jump in.
That's one that we got too fast.
Tim Ferriss: So you've mentioned a number
of your partners, Matt Cohler, who was also
very helpful for Uber, seems to be very good
at using himself as the guinea pig.
Very smart guy.
What are some of the lessons you've learned
from your partners?
And that could be anyone, Fenton, Lasky, Cohler,
anyone.
You don't even necessarily have to mention
names.
I'm just curious what their superpowers are
or what you have adapted, learned from them.
Bill Gurley: So I'd probably go back to some
of the founding partners because those were
the ones that I learned from.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Bill Gurley: One of them, I'd say from Bruce
Dunlevie, is just have a really big tent.
We're in a networking business where you're
trying to look under every rock for the next
possible deal.
And cutting off avenues of information or
flow is just a really stupid idea.
And so it ties in with what could go right,
but just be super open-minded.
And so Bruce had been involved with a company
that I think was in a software tool space,
the name escapes me.
We could look it up.
And had developed a lot of friendships, went
down the organizational chart at the company.
And one day, one of the engineers from that
company comes to him and says, "I'm working
on this marketplace thing called eBay."
And he was from a different industry, Bruce,
but because he had developed that relationship
that came in, now, it turned out that Bob
Kagle was much more excited about eBay than
Bruce was.
And so Bruce made that intro because we're
equal partnership, that's all cool.
And Bob ends up doing the deal and becomes
the number-one-ranked VC in the land.
But it all came from that relationship.
So big tent.
The older I get, I just take the time, be
kind, be available, it pays off.
At least in our industry, it pays off big
time.
So that's one.
Venture, another one is just, and this is
more specific to venture, but unless you're
super lucky — there were two VCs I know
that were very fortunate, Cohler and Roelof,
both at Sequoia who — Roelof with YouTube
and Matt with Instagram, where they had a
hit two years in.
But for the vast majority of venture capitalists,
they don't have a liquidity event till year
eight or nine.
And so it's easy to doubt yourself.
And three years in, people like to use the
child age analogy, you've got 12-year-olds
becoming 13-year-olds, and your whole portfolio's
like that with acne all over their face, and
you can really lose confidence.
So one thing that a lot of my partners did
was just like, "It's going to be okay, get
back out there.
You're good.
You're doing fine."
That kind of thing, which was way more helpful
than you could possibly imagine because the
anxiety was spiking.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to come back to open
source in a minute, but first I'm wondering,
you've mentioned a number of books that are
broadly applicable to entrepreneurship, and
I'm sure translate to, as you mentioned, investing
in a number of capacities.
If you were advising someone or just mentoring
someone who wanted to learn how to be a good
angel investor or venture capitalist in tech,
what might you suggest to them in terms of
approach or resources, books, anything?
Bill Gurley: I'll give you a few more books
and then obviously the world's different today,
the content consumption is so different.
But there's a book I love called Startup by
Kaplan.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I bought that when I first moved to Silicon
Valley in '99.
That was one of the very first books.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, it's just fantastic.
He was in the — what do they call that world?
Because it's where General Magic was.
It was like the first portable computers.
Every one of them failed, every one, but they
all raised massive amounts of money.
He, on his ride home every day, had a cassette
tape and left an archive or a diary, which
makes the book so good because the detail
is fantastic.
But they had the best venture capitalists,
they had the best advisors, they had the best
executives, and the executives that were in
— this was GO Corp, I think, that were there.
All went on to do amazing things.
But this company failed hard, failed hard.
And I think it's nice to combine a book of
failure with all the books of success.
I just think it's super educational.
Interestingly, if you read that, you should
probably also simultaneously watch the General
Magic documentary.
Tim Ferriss: It's so good.
Yeah.
Bill Gurley: Because they were a competitor
with GO, so it'd be — and the same story.
And the people there all went on to wild success.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's like the Jodorowsky's Dune where Giger,
who went on to create the iconic design for
Alien and Aliens.
I mean, they're just these failures that contain
an all-star team and fail for any number of
factors, but General Magic, I just want to
second that recommendation.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, it's fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: If people want an additional
inside look, listen to my interview with Tony
Fadell, which goes into great depth on that.
Bill Gurley: And on Tony, I'd read his new
book, Build.
Tim Ferriss: It's solid.
It's very strong.
Yeah.
Bill Gurley: And it's got a lot of frameworks,
and you can agree with them or not agree with
them.
But I do think entrepreneurs benefit from
frameworks because just running by the seat
of your pants, you need a framework for having
weekly meetings.
You need a framework for executive recruiting.
You need a framework for development of your
team.
And there are a lot of good ones.
There's probably 20 good ones of each of those,
but the worst thing you can possibly do is
have no framework and just kind of seat of
your pants.
And by the way, that's the most frequent solution,
the absolute no framework.
I would mention Shoe Dog.
I don't know if the reality had as many near-death
experiences as the book makes it sound like,
but it's good to see the tenacity you need.
This is the Phil Knight Nike book, but the
tenacity you need to make it is high.
You shouldn't start — if you're starting
a company because you think it's going to
be a good lifestyle, holy shit.
You're in for a rude awakening.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
So the same writer who penned Shoe Dog in
reality is the same person who did Open, the
autobiography of Agassi, which is another
spectacular book.
Bill Gurley: And apparently the new Harry
book that I —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no kidding.
All right.
That's a selling point because I think it's
Moehringer is a spectacular, spectacular —
Bill Gurley: J.D.
Moehringer, yeah, yeah.
He's fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So Shoe Dog.
So far, these are company-building books,
which is totally valid, of course.
Bill Gurley: For kind of high-tech macro,
if there is such a thing, I think Ridley's
two books, The Rational Optimist and How Innovation
Works, they're just fantastic and spectacular.
They're much higher level, but they're really,
really good.
Tim Ferriss: What makes them good?
Bill Gurley: Well, the first book, Ridley
has this point of view that I think is very
hard to dispute, that the vast majority of
wealth creation and increase of standard of
living for humans on the planet come from
two things, commerce and ideas.
What he calls "ideas having sex."
So if you think about if someone comes up
with a new farming technique, the marginal
cost of that is zero.
And if you pass it along to someone, their
productivity improves.
And so it's super powerful in my mind, especially
when I think about people.
A lot of people on the planet want to improve
the standard of living of a lot of people.
And I look at what Deng Xiaoping did in China
and say, I don't know that any other human
in the history of the world has unlocked as
much standard of living increase as this one
human by bringing capitalism to China.
And anyway, it's something that really speaks
to me in terms —
Tim Ferriss: On a much smaller scale, but
people should study Lee Kuan Yew and well,
just the whole Singapore story.
I mean, basically taking it from a swamp to
what it is today is just an incredible, but
I agree on the Deng Xiaoping piece.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
So then and on other content, the world's
way different now, right?
With podcasts and blogs and Twitter and all
these kind of things so no matter what you're
doing, but especially if you want to do venture
attack, there's lots of people that talk their
book, that talk their game like follow, listen,
read, consume, consume, read, read, read,
read.
I don't think you can get too much information.
Tim Ferriss: Well, let's segue to open source.
What else do you think open source might be
able to solve?
And I've had some reasonably direct experience
with watching, I suppose one example of what
you described, which is Automattic and very
good friend Matt Mullenweg.
I'm an advisor to Automattic, and for those
who don't know, Matt, who's been on the show
multiple times, was a lead developer of WordPress,
very familiar with open source, and then has
built a sort of services and enterprise grade
secure, stable solution for many different
businesses and people in the form of Automattic.
So I'm deeply interested in this, and I know
you are as well.
You're a big fan of open source.
What else do you think open source could be
applied to or might be applied to?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
So first of all, I think people are relatively
familiar with the big individual software
projects.
Linux being the most well known.
It's over 20 years old now.
It's clearly the most used operating system
in the world.
And what people might not know about it is
a lot of scientists believe it's the most
secure.
And that's kind of counterintuitive.
Oh, all the code's public, how could it be
the most secure?
But it gets beat up the most, because it's
used the most.
There's a great piece of writing, an incredible
piece of writing called The Cathedral and
the Bazaar that was the first kind of magnum
opus on why this open source thing might work.
And another thing people don't get is The
Cathedral and the Bazaar compared– Like,
are you trying to build up the Gaudí's Church
or Bizarre, which is super flat and wide and
obviously built by lots of people.
And the thing is, open source is way better
at complex problems than simple problems.
And it's the very complex problems that'd
be hard for a single company to do.
And so if you're building an operating system,
it might have all kind of edges on how it
integrates with other systems, different drivers
you might need, and the world is able to build
that, whereas an individual company would
be very difficult.
And so we started to see that in MySQL and
there've been others like MongoDB and we're
in one called Elastic and there've been a
lot of successful companies around single
software frameworks.
Something started happening about 10 to 15
years ago, which is people started using open
source in more complex ways and in sometimes
using it defensively rather than offensively.
So the most well known is probably Android.
So Apple had come out with this smartphone,
you could only get it on AT&T.
It's scared the shit out of everybody, not
just Google, but it's scared the out of all
the other telcos.
It's scared the out of all the other handset
manufacturers.
And so Google did this clever thing they said,
"Oh, we're going to create a competitor, but
it's going to be open source so you can trust
us."
Now there's different versions of how open
something is, and Android's not very open,
but at the time, compared to the threat of
Apple, it seemed like a much better trade.
And so they got the world behind them on this
thing, and it took off.
Since then, that model's been repeated in
some esoteric ways.
Facebook has something called The Open Compute
Project and if you want your hardware to go
into the Facebook data server room, it has
to be compatible with their open source framework.
And what that means is no one can have an
IP claim against Facebook because you've basically
sworn off your IP.
So they're commoditizing the stuff they're
going to purchase.
Since then, AT&T and China Mobile have worked
with The Linux Foundation to do the same thing
for the wireless and wire line equipment stack.
So they're defining open standards for their
next gen products.
And if you're a supplier that wants to sell
to them, you have to agree to those standards.
And once again, you're out of the IP game
so they don't get held up.
It's very clever stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Would you mind just expanding
on that a little bit?
The IP piece?
Bill Gurley: Well, let's go to the Facebook
one because it's more understandable.
It's called the Open Compute Foundation.
It's managed by the Linux Foundation acts
as a steward much in the way that the crypto
world thinks DAO manages this loose federation.
The Linux Foundation does that.
Linux has been a DAO for 25 years, it's super
interesting.
So that group, they're like a nonprofit overseer
of the project break ties.
They do patent defense, which I think is super
interesting.
So they pull patents in, no one sues within
the open source project, but if someone were
to come attack it, you'd go out after.
So anyway, Facebook has all these equipment
in their data center, networking equipment,
storage equipment, computers, software.
So they just created this thing called the
Open Compute Foundation that defines open
standards for how all these products work.
And so if you want to be on their purchasing
list, you say, "Yes, we are compatible with
this open standard."
And once again, it basically commoditizes
that equipment.
And once again, so —
Tim Ferriss: It just gives Facebook more leverage
with —
Bill Gurley: Yes but now —
Tim Ferriss: A broader spectrum of suppliers.
Bill Gurley: Every one of these things has
a website and you can go see and so now Amazon
and Google, they're all a part of Open Compute.
Tim Ferriss: I got it.
If I'm understanding you correctly, tell me
if I'm missing something, they're trying to
create conditions such that they wouldn't
end up back in the day when I moved to Silicon
Valley, I worked in storage area networking,
and EMC at the time was pretty famous for
being a black box.
If anything broke, if anything went wrong,
you needed EMC to fix it or upgrade it and
so to avoid being held hostage or losing leverage
with suppliers, Facebook made this move.
Is that a fair description?
Bill Gurley: Absolutely.
And then another high profile one, Google
was very worried about Amazon.
Tim Ferriss: It's genius.
I mean, it's very smart.
Bill Gurley: Oh, it's super clever.
Amazon was very afraid of — I mean Google
was very afraid of Amazon running away with
the cloud services business in AWS.
And so they had a piece of technology called
Kubernetes, and this was right around when
Docker and containerization took off, and
Kubernetes was an orchestration layer for
containers.
And Google decided, Hey —
Tim Ferriss: What a bizarre name.
What was it?
Kubernetes?
Sounds like an Italian pasta.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Well, here's the thing though.
They decided that it was in their best interest
to take this technology and gift it to an
open source consortium.
They got the Linux Foundation to manage it,
and they went out and recruited IBM and HP
and all these other vendors to say, "Oh, yeah,
we'll support Kubernetes," because everyone
wanted to make sure that people weren't locked
in to Amazon.
And eventually it got so successful that Amazon
had to announce support for Kubernetes.
And now if you need to move a workload from
Google to Amazon, there's a common framework
for which to do that and so you're less locked
in.
Tim Ferriss: So this seems like it's become,
at least based on the examples you gave, a
very refined, reliable counterpunch that Google
uses.
Bill Gurley: I call it defensive corporate
strategy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Bill Gurley: I'll give you two more very recently.
Well, there's always been OpenStreetMaps.
And that's kind of interesting because it's
data rather than — but the OpenStreetMap
team was very kind of non-commercial.
So they didn't like when Apple — and Google's
obviously running away with the maps business
so if you just look this up within the past
four weeks, there's a new open source map
group that's going to live on top of OpenStreetMap
that has Facebook and Microsoft and the other
parties that don't want Google to run away
with it.
And quite frankly, I think that's pretty cool.
If you talk to — actually, someone you should
have on if I think that would be really cool
is Jim Zemlin, who's run The Linux Foundation
for this whole time.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, good idea.
Bill Gurley: He's a huge believer and this
kind of ties into Matt Ridley's "ideas having
sex" that not having IP is actually great
for the world because it just creates constraints
for people being able to take advantage of
things.
And so mapping’s super interesting to me
because it's data oriented.
There's something called RISC-V, which is
an open source processor, believe it or not,
that has a lot of momentum now.
You'll see people on the earnings calls for
ARM, they'll start, “Is this a competitor?
Is this going to be a problem?”
Because it's completely free licensed and
China is a big backer of open source, and
you could understand why because the West
has accused them of IP thefts.
So this is where you can't be accused.
Tim Ferriss: Safe space.
So they– Safe space.
Bill Gurley: They're investing like crazy.
But I wonder what's possible.
I'll give you some kind of grander ideas.
First of all, I think autonomous vehicles
should definitely be open source.
I think everyone benefits, safety's higher,
communication layers are better.
The idea that you would use artificial intelligence
to figure out whether a light is red, yellow,
or green is really stupid because it's a state
machine.
It is in one of those three states and that
could be communicated into the software.
You don't need to infer that, that's a known
thing, but you need a common language.
And your test suites could all be used by
everyone.
Academia could be working on the same thing
that the corporations are, safety's higher,
easier for government to get involved if it's
a single standard.
And I wonder about other things like the NIH
gives out $40 billion a year and many of these
projects end up as research that leads to
a drug that leads to having a 17-year patent
life and gets sold at 300 grand a year or
whatever.
Why wouldn't we say, if you take NIH dollars,
your research is open source?
Why do we use government dollars to fund stuff
that becomes proprietary?
That didn't make any sense to me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This is something that you and I can have
a conversation about separately.
Bill Gurley: I look at the state of nuclear
energy where the costs are high because of
regulation, not because of the actual product
and I wonder, what if the globe had a standard
for fission-based nuclear reactor?
Wouldn't we get to lower price points, wouldn't
we get to safer products, wouldn't they get
more involved?
It seems possible to me.
Tim Ferriss: Are there any companies that
are on a short list of companies you would
love to see exist or types of companies, like
anything that's just kind of a bee in your
bonnet or has been for any period of time?
Bill Gurley: Yeah I can give you a few.
So, and this one's kind of well known in the
venture industry, but everybody talks about
something called the interest graph, and they
wonder why there isn't an internet website
that kind of links everyone that is tied to
a specific interest.
And there are companies that people talk about
as being close, like Pinterest or Quora or
Twitter, but I don't think any of them have
really pulled it off.
Tim Ferriss: Would Reddit fall anywhere?
Bill Gurley: Sure.
Especially with some of the subreddits they're
getting close and people talk about kind of
a holy grail, but there's not anyone that's
I think just really nailed it, really, really
nailed it.
And if you did, you would have this combination
of really cool unlock for people because you'd
get connect– if you were into quilting,
you'd be immediately connected with everyone
else that's on your level and you could imagine
that kind of thing.
But then the advertising performance would
just be off the charts because you've kind
of bucketed everyone into these places.
I actually think Twitter still has a huge
opportunity on this front, but it'd have to
build a top-down version of Twitter rather
than this feed thing, which is super hard
for a lot of people.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by top-down?
Bill Gurley: I think you could take all of
the information that's flowing in Twitter
and all of the influencers that are in there
and build an algorithm that would score who's
smart about certain things.
Let's make it super simple to convey the point.
If you look at stocks, so they already have
a new idea, unique individual identifier for
each stock with the dollar symbol thing.
But right now, you could do a search, but
there's a ton of noise.
What if you had a page where, for each stock,
you had a list of the top stories of the day,
and that could be pulled out of the Twitter
feed by knowing which people are the axes
on that individual stock, which you could
infer simply with the data that's already
in there.
And so you could imagine that for sports teams.
So I could have Twitter sports that is a top-down
version that's using the information in the
feed, but then presents it more like a standard
newspaper would, if you understand what I'm
getting at.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah, I think I do.
Bill Gurley: So anyway, that one's one.
I'm highly interested in people, feel free
to reach out in any variation or new take
on LinkedIn.
I just think it kind of stopped and it stopped
10 years ago.
One idea that —
Tim Ferriss: Aren't you semi-retired, Bill?
Aren't you semi-retired?
Bill Gurley: People will probably steal your
—
Tim Ferriss: Your version of retirement is
super intense.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
People may steal this and that's okay, but
I hope they reach out to me.
It feels to me like you could have page rank
for people.
And so I don't think the skill thing on LinkedIn
works because it's public so you get all this
performance art where people are just being
nice.
But what if you had people maybe privately
opining on who they think is smartest on particular
topics?
You can develop a really cool product that
would be unique to each individual.
Because what you see, Tim, would be different
than what I see because it starts by who you
trust and then what you see is there — anyway,
I think that's a really interesting concept.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I wonder if Twitter could
actually use the literal page rank by correlating
sort of verified account, that's become kind
of unusable for me because it was kind of
pay for play for a while so it's it difficult
to filter now.
But if people have websites that are their
personal websites, just looking at the page
rank, I mean seems like from a shooting side,
pretty easy to do.
Bill Gurley: I think one thing Twitter could
do that would just be a super industry is
create a leaderboard for every topic under
the sun.
And then the things you could build once you
had that would be super compelling.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Let's talk about Twitter, specifically a tweet
thread, and feel free to amend this, but I'd
love to have you walk me through this particular
thread.
This is from spring of 2022.
It's not that long ago, and here it goes.
So there are four points under an intro and
I'll just read it if you don't mind.
"An entire generation of entrepreneurs and
tech investors built their entire perspectives
on valuation during the second half of a 13-year
amazing bull market run.
The 'unlearning' process could be painful,
surprising, and unsettling to many.
I anticipate denial."
Number one.
And maybe we could just do these point by
point.
Well, we don't have to.
I'll do two at a time.
"1) Previous 'all-time' highs are completely
irrelevant.
It's not 'cheap' because it is down 70%.
Forget those prices happened."
Yeah, I screwed myself on that first one.
"2) Valuation multiples are always a hack
proxy.
Dangerous to use.
If you insist, 10X should be considered AMAZING
and an upper limit.
Over that, silly."
So let's just sit on those two for a second.
Would you mind just expanding on either or
both of those?
Bill Gurley: There's an unfortunate reality
in the venture world that really became very
crystal clear to me through a conversation
with Howard Marks, actually.
But it's structurally set up.
People talk about boom, bust, and cycles,
but this is set up more like a sawtooth.
So risk on happens very slowly, almost like
the rollercoaster [makes sound of slowly climbing
roller coaster].]
But when it crashes, and if it's interesting
to you, I explain or do my best job of explaining
why it's structured this way, when it crashes
it happens all at once so it's more like a
sawtooth than a sine wave and it just crashes
and it's painful.
And that just happened and it looks like it
happens every 7 to 15 years.
And I thought this was going to happen six
years ago.
I even wrote some things.
I was way early.
It took six more years and it got ridiculously
crazy.
But it took so long from '09, which was the
last kind of — and '09 wasn't as hard a
reset as '01 but from '09 to 2013, because
so many entrepreneurs are young, you had people
grow up that had never seen a reset and risk
on is a lot like the bull frog.
You don't know what's happening.
You're just —
Tim Ferriss: Would you mind just quickly defining
risk on for people listening, what do you
mean by that?
Bill Gurley: So the community as a whole takes
on more risk gradually without realizing they're
doing it and their mental models and their
frameworks adjust daily to what's happening.
And so their thought about how the world works
is really a window of five years, or maybe
three years, not 30 years.
Because for many of them, they don't have
the 30-year perspective and when the going
gets good, greed takes over and you weigh
the data points that feel good to you and
are going to make you look —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah a lot of confirmation bias.
Yeah.
Bill Gurley: Oh, like crazy, and so then you've
shortened your window to the last 12 months.
This is how the world works.
And because things got so sloppy with interest
rates being near zero, speculation so high,
money everywhere, we taught a lot of people
not only valuation things that will never
be true again, but growth at all costs.
Spend as much money as you can, you can raise
money every nine months if you want to because
you could, the failure rate of companies in
the five years prior to this reset is probably
the super low, probably the lowest it's ever
been, failure rate of startups just because
it was so easy to raise money.
And so you develop mental models and then
the world shifts dramatically, 180 degrees,
whatever you want to say.
It couldn't be more dramatic how fast it shifted
and even today, entrepreneurs will say, well,
I just need to hold on until things get back
to normal and I'm not the only one.
Tim Ferriss: Not normal.
Bill Gurley: This is normal, dude.
That was a fantasy you were in and you need
to forget it fast, but you can't.
And there's another painful thing that I don't
even jest about because it creates real problems
and it's actually quite unfortunate, but founders,
whatever that peak valuation is, they ran
the math where they took their ownership,
they multiplied it by that number, and they
thought about their net worth that way.
And that can just be super destructive once
it's no longer true.
It's just —
Tim Ferriss: You mean psychologically destructive?
Bill Gurley: Psychologically yeah, I think
it's super difficult to come to terms with
once you've been through that.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by valuation
multiples are always a hack proxy?
Bill Gurley: So this gets into some of the
earlier stuff we talked about, just about
how deep you go on investing history and understanding
investors.
But Silicon Valley, if there was a scale of
financial sophistication between one and 10,
and you would say a really smart person in
New York is an 8.5, the average Silicon Valley
person on financial literacy is a two.
And it's funny because they make fun of Wall
Street, but it's just out of ignorance, they
don't know anything.
And so most of them think about valuation
by a price to revenue multiple, which couldn't
be a cruder tool.
And at one point I wrote a blog post called
"The Keys to the 10X Revenue Club," and I
took all the public tech stocks and laid them
end to end based on price to revenue and one
of them was at 20 and one of them was at 0.1
and it was just a big curve.
So there's no line there.
There's no reason to believe that that price
to revenue is how you should value anything.
But just because it's easy, and these companies
are young and immature, it's hard to do DCF.
It's hard to do something more sophisticated.
It's the common language of the group.
But things changed overnight.
And so someone was pointing out, I think on
Twitter, that and they used price to gross
margin instead of price revenue.
Still, Twilio went from 70 times gross margin
to three in a very short window.
I mean, talk about valuation reset, that is
just radical.
And so it shakes the industry and no one's
going to feel sorry for Silicon Valley.
And I'm not trying to elicit empathy, but
in terms of understanding what happens, it
is so foundational, the change is so radical
that the best thing you can possibly have
happen is if you can adjust your mental models
fast and get on with the new world, but it's
very hard for people to do.
And, by the way, I write that kind of stuff
in part to help the industry, and I'm super
grateful, Sequoia in '09 put out, there's
a famous deck they put out "[R.I.P.]
Good Times" or something like that.
And these things help people adjust faster,
right?
Having minimal models that — having structure,
having smart people tell them, "Okay," it
gets them there faster.
Tim Ferriss: So that I think relates to number
three, and you mentioned DCF, just for people
who don't have that reference, discounted
cash flow.
So number three is:
"3) You may be shocked to learn that people
want to value your company on FCF…"
That's free cash flow free.
Am I getting that right?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yep. "...and earnings.
Facebook trades at 14X GAAP EPS…"
Am I pronouncing that correctly?
Bill Gurley: Yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: Yes. "...and is growing 23%.
What earnings multiple are you assuming?"
So could you just walk us through that bullet?
Bill Gurley: Yeah, yeah.
No, I'm going to use a little bit of detail
so you can understand.
But the point that — so if you think all
companies should —
Tim Ferriss: I am, at best, at two on the
financial literacy.
Bill Gurley: If you think all companies should
trade it like 10X revenue, here's one of the
most successful companies of all time that
is producing massive amounts of positive cash
flow and GAAP-audited earnings that's trading
at a very low multiple of those GAAP earnings.
And earnings are a small percentage of your
revenue, right?
So if you're trading at 10 times revenue,
you're probably trading at 50 times earnings.
And here they're trading at 14.
Or you may not even have earnings because
there's a great graph, we should try and find
it one so that someone can see a link of the
percentage of companies at IPO that are profitable
and it's this nice cyclical wave that goes
with these boom-bust cycles because Wall Street
—
Tim Ferriss: We'll find it and put it in the
show notes.
Bill Gurley: So Wall Street does risk on also,
right?
And so in really dark times, the percentage
of companies that are profitable is like 90,
but by 2020, 2021, that number's five percent.
The vast majority of companies are losing
money as they go public and Wall Street's
encouraging that behavior.
And so I've often said the venture like Wall
Street is the buyer of what venture capital
produces and if Wall Street wants high-growth,
money-losing businesses, we will create as
many as they can possibly consume.
Because those are a lot easier to build than
the profitable ones, way easier, which is
part of the cycle, that's part of why you
end up in this cycle thing.
So anyway, the point of highlighting that
is just to try and get entrepreneurs and founders
reset on where the world is today and where
valuations are.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sorry to interrupt, and I'm
sure a lot of people listening will think
this is a stupid question because they already
know the answer, but why did you highlight
Facebook in the way that you highlighted Facebook?
Bill Gurley: Just because I think on a historical
basis, Facebook is trading at a very low multiple.
It looks like a very weak stock.
I mean, Coca-Cola for years traded at 30,
35 times earnings, Facebook is at 14 — or
Meta, whatever they like to be called.
And 23 percent is a pretty impressive growth
rate for a company like this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
For sure.
Bill Gurley: Coke is less than 10 percent
growth, like five or three.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Since you mentioned Meta, I mean on one level
I really have to admire the just doubling
down on the Metaverse, what is your take on
this direction?
Bill Gurley: So years ago, I read Snow Crash
when it came out.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so good.
Bill Gurley: Thought it was the best thing
that I had ever consumed.
And I was in hook, line, and sinker.
so when Philip Rosedale started Second Life,
I was knocking on his door.
I served on that board for 12 years.
I have immense knowledge on this kind of immersive
stuff and Philip and I actually did a postmortem
podcast recently, which I would point people
to.
What we found is I think there's a difference
between the kind of gaming stuff and this
idea that people want to live experiences
like they do in the real world in this virtual
world.
And what we learned in that second category,
and I see this in the Facebook demos and stuff,
like, "Oh, we're going to do a board meeting
in-world," or whatever, is that that doesn't
make a lot of sense.
The number of people that love escapism, first
of all, young people do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you don't want to wait
in line at the postal office in your Second
Life.
Bill Gurley: Right.
Well, but young people do it.
They role-play a lot and so that makes sense.
And then a handful of adults do it.
They have wooden swords in the park or Burning
Man is that experience.
But it's not a high percentage of humans.
And one thing we found quite interestingly
is a lot of the people that love it are looking
for an escape so they may actually have mental
health problems or they're in a tough spot
in their life.
And it reminds you that both Snow Crash and
Ready Player One were dystopian novels, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Bill Gurley: People were escaping a world
that sucked.
And so we did a bunch of in world board meetings
there, and this is pre-Zoom.
Zoom is an amazing substitute, which is one
of the frameworks from competitive strategy,
to the notion of being in world.
And so it's got even harder, because I think
Zoom's way better for a board meeting than
making everyone get an avatar and sitting
around.
I just don't think that's going to happen.
So it's a long answer, but I think the premise
they have is wrong.
I don't think this becomes the next platform,
the next smartphone.
I don't see that.
Tim Ferriss: So how do you reconcile that
with the position that they're trading cheaply?
I guess that's just based on the math, but
is the —
Bill Gurley: Oh, I think Wall Street's on
my side on this one.
I think if they shut down the VR effort, not
only– Well, the profitability would soar
because they're spending real money, like
five to 10 billion a year, but I think the
stock doubles.
Doubles.
Tim Ferriss: Where would you suggest they
redirect their resources if they were to cancel
—
Bill Gurley: I don't even take credit for
this because people are saying it all over
Twitter.
There's really good buzz on some of their
AI tools and the world's super excited about
that.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, they are, my God.
Look at OpenAI and the Microsoft investment
and so on.
It's incredible.
Bill Gurley: I think it's a longer conversation,
but I think WhatsApp has some interesting
things going on.
What's happening there?
Tim Ferriss: Did you give a teaser of what
you —
Bill Gurley: Yeah, and if you read about WhatsApp
in India it has a similar place in the world
that Tencent with WeChat does in China, they've
accomplished more.
So those things are more interesting to me.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm curious, I've had Mark
Zuckerberg on the podcast and he's a man of
strong conviction.
I'm curious from your perspective, like zero
to a hundred percent, where would you put
the likelihood that he would ever can the
VR efforts and redirection?
Bill Gurley: It's funny, a lot of people love
to discuss this, and what's that other–
There's a bias when you get pot committed,
to me that's confirmation bias too, but if
you've already bought something, you like
it way more.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, sunk cost, well, sunk
cost fallacy.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's super hard.
And he's had people telling him what I just
said for two years now.
So it's interesting because if you look at
other big bets like that, I think the two
most amazing are AWS and Android.
They were both kind of out of left field,
not part of their core business, but super
successful.
And I think you've already run the clock,
you've already spent way more than either
of those did in the development of those things.
And you just don't have the numbers.
There was a thing going around Twitter that
the year-over-year sales of headsets is down
globally for the industry.
It's not happening.
Tim Ferriss: All right, let's hop to number
four.
"4) Revenue and earnings QUALITY matter."
Could you please explain the word "quality?"
Bill Gurley: Yeah, it's interesting that that's
like a nuanced thing.
If you talk to someone who'd been investing
on Wall Street for 15 years, you could talk
about revenue or earnings quality and they
would know exactly what you were talking about,
but it's not something the average person
would know.
And if that blog post again that I wrote called
"The Keys to the 10x Revenue Club," I go through
12 different things that signify quality,
but —
Tim Ferriss: And we'll link to that in the
show notes.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, so I mean, a simple one
is margins.
If you are reselling used cars and your revenue
is the price of the cars you're selling, but
you're only making 10 percent on a car, that's
really low revenue quality compared to a SaaS
vendor with 90 percent gross margins.
When their incremental dollar of revenue creates
90 cents of gross margin, yours creates 7
cents of gross margin.
You can't value those companies both on price
to revenue.
They're very different.
So that would be revenue quality.
Earning qualities typically relates to cash
flow.
So you might have really good GAAP earnings,
but because of different factors in your business,
your cash flows may not be nearly as good.
It could be timing differences, those kind
of things.
And so anyway, you'd go through the posts
that I wrote, but they're just elements of
whether or not you have a competitive advantage
whether or not you have churn in your business,
is this customer going to stay around forever
or they might leave tomorrow?
One of the reasons Coca-Cola trades at a high
multiple is everyone imagines Coke will still
be here 50 years from now.
They have no reason not to believe that.
Whereas some of these tech companies, why
is Facebook at 14?
They don't know.
Could TikTok take away their business and
then they're done overnight?
Those become bigger risks for tech companies
sometimes because they look like they might
be disruptable.
Tim Ferriss: You mentioned, and you also write
about and speak about competitive advantage
a lot, let me rephrase that question, what
are some lesser known or undervalued competitive
advantages?
Bill Gurley: Well, I mean we already talked
about network effect, that's one that just
comes to mind right away.
Lock in we had hinted at is there reasons
why switching costs, which is also it's in
the Porter book.
Are there switching costs that make it hard
to leave for a customer to leave?
How many substitutes are there for your product?
How unique is it?
Right?
That's a competitive advantage.
It's like are you an N of one?
And some of the network effect companies become
that way.
I could create an Instagram competitor, but
I don't have everyone on it.
So the user experience is a function of everyone
being on it so it's hard to compete with that
thing.
So you have a strong competitive advantage.
It could be performance like an enterprise
product, you look at something like Snowflake.
People just say, "This database does things
no other database will do," and so then that
becomes a competitive advantage.
But how hard is it for someone to find an
alternative to you and trade you out is an
easy way of being.
Tim Ferriss: This is not directly related
to competitive advantage, but I wanted to
just revisit the total addressable market
and your OpenTable story with the spreadsheet
or the model that had been capped at 17 percent
and you were like, "We're going to 99 percent,
it's not 70 percent."
Just to reflect back also on Uber, since you
and I were both along for that ride, pun intended,
and in the early days there were three black
cars, two or three black cars in the very,
very early days sort of prototyping.
And I remember sitting with Garrett and looking
at some of the potential market sizes, but
the assumption always was that the pie could
grow and should grow if Uber's functioning
effectively and that's what ended up happening.
So you can't say there are 700 black cars
in San Francisco, what percentage of those
will use Uber, and the upper limit is 700
because then in the matter of a handful of
years you have a thousand plus black cars
because of the rider demand.
So I just wanted to mention that since you'd
also mentioned it earlier.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, I wrote a very long piece
on this because there's a famous, I think
NYU professor, his last name's not coming
to me right now, but he's famous for valuation
work.
He's always on CNBC and he wrote a piece that
said Uber wouldn't be worth more than, I don't
know if it was two or three billion dollars
and I wrote a reply called “How to Miss
by a Mile.”
Tim Ferriss: Aswath Damodaran, I believe.
Bill Gurley: Yes it is and he's wonderful.
I called him before I published it just to
tell him it was coming, but it was a classic
mistake.
He basically took the taxi market and said,
"That's the upper limit," and that's just
the wrong, like, math we made, or Travis and
the team made this thing so convenient and
so available that it was a product that's
10x better than the taxi market.
And by the time I wrote that, I already knew
that Uber in San Francisco was 20x bigger
than the taxi market in San Francisco.
So I already knew he was wrong with that analysis.
We'd already belonged through it, but he didn't
know that.
And I mentioned in that article, there's a
couple of classic examples of this, there
was one where McKinsey was hired to calculate
the global market for mobile phones and came
back with 900,000.
And I have found you get into more trouble
with this kind of TAM conservatism, then it
hurts you more than it helps you as an investor.
If you feel like something's super disruptive
and it's unlocking things like your optionality
to build on top of, that's going to be pretty
spectacular.
Tim Ferriss: I was just going to say, it makes
me think of esports versus any comparable
you might use with, I don't know, live viewership
of sports or whatever.
It's just not the same thing.
So that was the one through four points.
Jeff Bezos, I think either retweeted or replied
to that tweet thread and with was very complimentary.
You have spent time with Jeff.
What do you think are some of the most underappreciated
aspects related to Jeff in any capacity?
Bill Gurley: Well, I mean he's probably the
best entrepreneur that I've ever been around
or got to know.
It's remarkable and it's multifaceted.
Here's one that I think is not well discussed
so he has a bunch of traits that make him
a great entrepreneur.
The company today is at such a radical scale
that there's no way, and I mean he's in the
chairman role, he's not touching all the decisions,
he's not touching all the product decisions,
he has built a organizational framework to
take what Jeff Bezos believes and run the
whole company that way and that's not well
dissected, not well understood.
But here's a great story, I'm riding in an
Uber, this is about eight or years ago, maybe
seven, and I always talk to him.
I always talk to the drivers because I'm a
shareholder and always talk to the driver
and I'm asking him something about whether
we can stop.
He goes, "Well, I've got to get back down
to San Jose by 2:30."
And I'm like, "What happens at 2:30?"
He goes, "I have to meet at the Amazon warehouse
at 2:30."
I go, "What's going on?"
He goes, "Oh, they've got this new program
they're running where you show up at 2:30
and they have all these burner phones and
they load your car with packages and give
you a manifest and then they booked a ride
over Uber."
And so this was the early days of same-day
delivery.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's cool.
Bill Gurley: This is a company that's worked
tens, hundred billions of dollars that is
running an experiment on top of Uber and I
know for a fact that most of the companies
I've worked with that have gotten over 20
or 30 million in revenue would not run that
experiment because someone would say, oh,
we won't know how to do the accounting, that's
too much of a hack, like whatever.
But this large company was super comfortable
running this kind of hack experiment on this
other company.
He showed me the manifest.
I looked at all this stuff.
Of course, I called Uber immediately thereafter
and briefed him that we were being used in
a — but unbelievable, I mean, just unbelievable.
No other large company would do that project,
none, zero.
And so somehow he's institutionalized this
kind of experimentation and risk seeking,
and he's talked about it.
There's a great interview with him from Code
that you should try and find for the show
notes from four or five years ago and I could
watch it over and over and over.
It's like the Eagles documentary I could just
watch it again and again.
But it's fascinating, someone asked him, "When
do you stop and experiment?"
And he said, "When the last person with judgment
gives up."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, when would he stop experimenting?
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just say that one more
time?
Bill Gurley: They ask him, "When does a internal
experiment get killed?"
And he said, "When the last person with good
judgment gives up."
And that's not how other big companies work.
They don't run experiments that way.
In fact, one of the reasons startups can compete
with big companies is because most big company
experiments, they run one test and if it fails,
they quit.
And a startup can't quit because they have
to shut down if they quit.
So they run experiment one and two and three
and four and five, and then they pivot and
do six and seven and eight, and they stay
up all night because it has to work.
And so they just get way more shots on goal
than the big companies do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Bezos is also someone who has chronicled a
lot of us thinking and decision-making frameworks
in letters to shareholders and there are some
compilations of his letters, much like Warren
Buffett.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, they're very good.
Tim Ferriss: And they're very good just to
give one example, I mean it can be highly
tactical.
So I mean, the reason that people who would
call internal meetings would be required to
put together, I think it was a six-page document
and the first 30 minutes of the meeting would
be spent reading this meticulous document
and all of the reasons for why that was instituted.
I mean, it's very concrete.
It's not sort of ambiguous hand wavy stuff.
So I definitely recommend people check that
out.
And also —
Bill Gurley: By the way, mirror back to what
we talked about earlier about writing and
thought process, if you're forced to write
a six-page paper, it's much harder to put
that together than it is a five-page PowerPoint.
It's easier to leave stuff out.
You really have to think through everything.
I mean, he's super curious beyond belief.
He's willing to change his priors super fast
if he got something wrong.
Yeah, it's something else.
I mean, I think AWS is maybe top five business
move in the history of the world.
I don't even know what — just the notion
that they launched that out of a consumer
internet company and became one of the most
important enterprise companies it's fairly
unprecedented, it's just amazing.
Tim Ferriss: It is jaw dropping.
And for people who want an Easter egg, if
you have not learned of this before, go to
relentless.com and see what happens.
It will forward directly to amazon.com and
that is not accidental.
So is there anything else that you'd like
to say about the recent events and sort of
correction/implosion or do you feel like you've
said what you would like to say, is there
anything you'd like to add?
Bill Gurley: One last comment I would make,
it was interesting, I was listening the other
day to a podcast with Shane Battier, who I've
been fortunate enough to meet.
He's the —
Tim Ferriss: I don't know who that is.
Bill Gurley: Oh, he was famously out outlined
by Michael Lewis as the no stat all-star in
The New York Times Magazine.
He's an NBA player, really successful, that
kind of rode the analytics craze and did things
that most people don't do, but when you ran
all the numbers, he's always winning and that
kind of thing.
And he played at Duke and has a ring from
the NBA.
And anyway, he's now starting to dip his toe
into the corporate world.
And so he did this podcast kind of a crossover,
but he was talking about Krzyzewski and how
Krzyzewski, he spent four years there and
so he had a lot of stories, but I was listening
and nodding because you've had great coaches
on, you've had great players on that play
for great coaches, and these learnings can
be translated.
And so he's saying, "Oh, Coach K. told us
that he expected the very must out of us.
Each individual had to perform at their highest
level.
He said, 'It's always team first.
If you need to be an individual, you don't
need to be here.'"
And Shane was talking about how people remember
the winners more than they remember whether
you were the third or fourth scorer on a team.
They remember the winners, and I think that's
true in startup world as well.
And then three, he said, there's a singular
goal for this organization and it's to win
the national championship.
And those three tenants, he is talking about
relatives to Coach K. and I'm in the middle
of nodding, and I was writing stuff down.
I'm like, oh, I'll go talk to people.
I'll go forward this podcast.
And then I stopped cold and I realized in
2020, 2021, if an internet entrepreneur stood
up and said those things out loud about what
he wanted from his company, he might get canceled.
Company first, you have to perform at your
absolute best and the only goal here is the
one goal of the corporation, we're all on
a team together.
We wandered to a place that's very different
than that.
And on your recent podcast with Jonathan,
he started to talk about the, I think you
were using the word anti-fragility, but how
this had crossed over from the campus world,
and these people were now —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
I was asking him how to develop intellectual
anti-fragility, and he was giving the counter-example
of what we've observed.
Bill Gurley: Right.
This happened in the university and this did
get out into the companies and so these companies
were being basically held accountable for
delivering an experience for the individual.
It's like your goal as a company is to help
the individual have a great life.
And I think it's very hard to be high performant.
Imagine if Coach K. had that problem, like
he had to make everyone make sure everyone
on the team felt happy and safe and included
and that was true north.
It would be very hard for him to be performing.
I don't think he'd want to coach him.
And we've lived through a little bit of a
reaction to this.
So Brian Armstrong at Coinbase has very publicly
spoken.
I think Tobi at Shopify took a little more
nuanced stance, but the same stance that like
we have one objective here, which is this
company.
And if you're hyper passionate about something
else that you got to talk about it all the
time with this company, maybe you should go
do that.
But this performance awareness had kind of
gone away because of everything I talked about.
It was so easy to survive as a company.
And now we're in a world where I think, you've
got to make hard choices, you've got to do
what's right, you've got to perform.
And so it'll be interesting to see whether
someone can act in this way without getting
negative and Brian took a lot of heat for
what he did.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It seems to have passed pretty quickly.
I mean, he was able to weather the storm and
take the heat, but it was pretty, I mean,
what he did for everyone.
Bill Gurley: I talk to executives at the bigger
companies are the ones we all know, they're
dealing with this stuff on a daily basis.
Tim Ferriss: Nonstop.
Bill Gurley: Nonstop.
And it's very similar to what's happening
at the university level.
And so it is just super curious to me just
because I've always been one of these, I played
sports in high school and college, and I've
always, when there's a winning team and the
coach writes a book, I've always ran out and
read it and made it part of my menbtal model
so it is kind of interesting to see where
we are.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think the future
of, you tell me if this is a question with
some there or not, but what do you think the
future of ecommerce looks like?
And since you mentioned Tobi, I'm a huge fan
of Tobi.
I mean, I was an advisor to Shopify super
early when they had about 10 employees, and
I just think he's one of the most incredible
humans out there.
But where do you think Shopify fits in or
doesn't fit into that?
It seems like with some of the Apple privacy
changes and all these various things the landscape
has changed super dramatically.
If you try to look into your experience/crystal
ball to look forward at ecommerce —
Bill Gurley: I'm a Tobi fan too, and at the
end of this, I'll tell a quick Tobi story
that I think is a wonderful, a tool that people
can use and he gave me permission to share
it.
So I thought what they did with the shop app
was super cool.
So the previous Christmas I started noticing
websites I'd never been to before, knew who
I was and allowed one click checkout.
And very few companies can make their business
as a B2B company and then have this crossover
product, which has a consumer network effect.
And they did that with that app and I thought
it was just super cool that they pulled that
off.
And so look, he is one of the truly greats,
and you've interviewed enough of these people
like when you're with a Bezos or a Tobi, you
kind of know it, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's different.
And Tobi's been on the podcast.
I recommend people check it out.
Yeah, it's just a different feeling.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
And they're hyper curious, they have their
own mental models, they're willing to learn
new ones, they're constantly thinking.
And they've built some type of organizational
fabric that's scaling, which is another element
of.
Here's the one he shared, which is one of
my favorite ever.
So he said, "Whenever we're dealing with a
problem and we call a meeting to talk about
the problem, I always start with this structure.
We are here to solve a problem.
So the one option that we know we're not going
to leave the room doing is the status quo.
That is off the table.
So whenever we finish this meeting, I want
to talk about what option we're taking, but
it's not going to be what we're currently
doing."
And I think that is brilliant because most
of the companies that I've ever worked with,
their default is, "Well, let's not change
it.
If we can't get the gumption to change something,
don't mess with it."
And I thought it was genius.
I just thought it was genius.
Tim Ferriss: He's also, I mean, not only an
incredibly smart, effective human and leader,
but a very humble, and I just admire him so
deeply, not just for the performance of the
company, but for how he carries himself in
the world.
I think it's just as impressive to me that
he carries that much horsepower but doesn't
wield it in a overbearing way, which would
be very easy to do, a lot of people do it.
So thanks.
Thank you, Tobi.
Bill Gurley: I agree.
I agree.
Tim Ferriss: So just a few more questions,
Bill and if this goes nowhere, I'll take the
blame for it.
So aside from the books that you have mentioned,
are there any books that you have gifted frequently
to other people?
Bill Gurley: Yes.
There are three books that I'll mention.
The first one that I've gifted the most is
called Complexity by Mitchell Waldrop, which
is about the rise of the Santa Fe Institute.
Even when you were talking with Haidt, I think
he mentioned certain things are complex adaptive
systems.
They're very hard to predict, they're very
hard to analyze, they're very hard to understand.
That's what Santa Fe's all about.
That book introduced me to network effects.
When I get to go there, I usually go a couple
times a year and Mike Mauboussin's there and
Josh Wolfe's there from Lockton.
I just love the learning of things I don't
know, and just pushing my brain to go farther
than I would with the normal stuff I consume.
It's beautifully written.
Great writer, Mr. Waldrop.
There's a book that I happen to have right
here.
This book, Mr. China is fantastic.
He went to China in the mid '90s and started
a fund to privatize a bunch of industries.
He's from London and got his head handed to
him and survived enough to write a humorous
story about it.
But holy shit.
Tim Ferriss: It sounds kind of like the Red
Notice by Bill Browder equivalent, but in
China.
Bill Gurley: His life didn't end up getting
threatened.
He did go to jail, but I read Red Notice.
Tim Ferriss: There was a Red Notice.
Yeah, yeah.
Bill Gurley: This is more of a business —
Tim Ferriss: There's no death involved.
Bill Gurley: This is more of a business book
and a know what you don't know and what can
happen to you when you go into a foreign land.
In the book that I've been fascinated with
the past five years, four or five years is
Epstein's Range.
David Epstein wrote a book called Range, which
it was kind of a counter punch to the 10,000-hour
thing by Malcolm Gladwell.
It started by talking about Federer.
But at the end of it, he got into a couple
of notions that I find super interesting.
A lot of the big breakthroughs in science
have come from people that have changed disciplines
or changed genres, which you're talking about
a lot, which I just find super fascinating.
If you go on Twitter, which obviously, there's
a lot of people shouting, but you'll constant
refrain is like, "Shut up.
You don't know anything about this field.
Leave it to the people in the field."
But if you study science and history, that's
not actually — the biggest breakthroughs
come from people that had a different middle
framework and move over and then see things
differently.
I think it's super interesting.
There's a professor at UCLA named Holyoak
who did a piece on something he calls far
analogies where he views it as an intellectual
skill, but who can borrow ideas from farther
away than where they are.
Listen to some podcast of this person in this
field and have it impact what they do.
I'm fascinated by everything in that world.
Tim Ferriss: Range, for people who want a
little bit more, the subtitle is: Why Generalists
Triumph in a Specialized World.
And I did recognize the name because of another
book, which is The Sports Gene.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, he wrote The Sports Gene.
Tim Ferriss: Inside the Science of Extraordinary
Athletic Performance, which is a great book.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The Santa Fe Institute.
Let's talk about just for a second or maybe
a minute or maybe more than a few minutes,
why is that important?
I mean, I suppose explained it in part, and
what have you gleaned from your involvement?
It seems like such another prominent commitment
on your part.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
Another individual that's been involved there
for a long time and has been the biggest benefactor
is a guy named Bill Miller, who was a very
famous Wall Street investor.
Had one of the, he was at Legg Mason and had
a 15-year run where he'd beat the SNP.
And I think for Michael, Bill, myself, and
Joshua, by listening and learning about analysis
of these types of systems and seeing professors
from all the — another big thing about Santa
Fe is that it's multidisciplinary, so they
have biologists hanging around with epidemiologists,
hanging around with physicists, and they all
interact together.
And Cormac McCarthy hangs out there too, which
is kind of cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that is cool.
Bill Gurley: And just hearing and learning,
you pick up things.
It's hard for me.
The network effect thing, I picked up the
first time I went there with Brian Arthur
and I applied that quite directly.
But there's other little things.
There was a speech that was given three or
four years ago about the electric grid problems
that were happening in North America.
The professor that presented it at the end
said, "The best solution is smaller communities
that are loosely coupled."
And that is a really interesting — you could
use that framework.
I walked up to her afterwards and I said,
"You just explained why the Euro's a bad idea,
because you tightly coupled this thing too
much."
And you can just imagine even a computer system
that's distributed, that learning could have
other applications.
If it's too distributed there's no scale.
But if it's hyper integrated, then you have
this failure problem, this global failure.
Anyway, that's an example.
Tim Ferriss: Do they have talks and so on
online, or is it more of a close group type
of experience?
Bill Gurley: They do.
There's lots of them online, you can see.
Yeah, they do.
They publish books.
Tim Ferriss: Great.
Bill Gurley: There's lots of stuff online.
It's cool.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so last one or two questions.
This one can go any number of directions,
but if you could put anything on a billboard,
this is metaphorically speaking, just to get
a message, a question, a prompt suggestion,
image, anything out to billions of people,
let's just assume they would all understand
it.
What might you put on that billboard?
Bill Gurley: I think circa 2023 and everything
that's happened over the past five or six
years, I would put “Be less tribal.”
“Be less tribal.”
And I have friends on both sides of the political
spectrum, and I can't imagine an activity
that turns off more brain cells than tribal
affiliates.
All the books that have been written on bias
and all the Kahneman [inaudible] and Thinking,
Fast and Slow, and all the Nobel prizes for
that stuff.
I think political bias is stronger than confirmation
bias, sunk cost, all those things.
People are just turning off their brains and
it's both directions.
And it's not just the fringe, it's not just
the populists.
It's people that just affiliate and then they
don't think, they don't listen.
And it's both sides.
I mean, I'll give you an example.
Gerrymandering.
Horrible.
They both do it.
It's horrible.
Yeah, just say it's horrible.
But they don't.
They say, "Oh, look.
Those guys are horrible when they do it.
Capture is horrible.
And on the Republican side, that's banks and
big pharma.
But on the other side it's unions, the teacher's
union and the police union.
George Floyd doesn't happen if the police
union doesn't have the power they did because
Derek Chauvin would've been off the force.
But the police union protected him.
And if you're on the left, you can't say that.
You can't make that statement.
You can't be anti-union.
And it's just stupid for people to turn their
brains off this much.
Anyway, I'm passionate about that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
How would you suggest — let's just say you
were teaching, you're a good teacher and you've
spoken to students.
If you were to give a presentation on cultivating
anti-tribalism, probably have a sexier headline
to it.
But what might that lecture or class contain
or blog post?
Bill Gurley: I think the first thing I would
try and do is just highlight the fact that
people are turning off their brains.
The way that people have proven how confirmation
bias works, how loss aversion works.
There's 20 different cognitive biases that
we're all aware of.
The first thing I would do is just run some
— there's been stuff done.
Then, why does anyone want to be intellectually
inconsistent?
If you think it's an ends to a means, then
you're just in a fight.
You're just in a fight.
I don't even want to have a discussion with
someone if cheating on your spouse and philandering
is okay when your side does it, but it's horrible
when the other side doesn't like, right.
What's your principle?
I don't understand.
Anyway, I would try and get people in touch
with the fact that they're doing it.
And then I would just highlight that our government's
far from perfect.
Most tribal people view their side as near
perfect, and there's no sign of that anywhere.
But there are a few orgs that I'm starting
to learn about.
Nonprofits that give money to centrist candidates
or things like that.
And I think the world, if you could go back
30 years, it was just more collegial across
the aisle.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, you've mentioned Twitter
a number of times.
I feel like Twitter incentivizes for polarization
just with the mechanisms at work.
And you're a good writer.
I wonder why you post so much on Twitter,
which seems so impermanent compared to a blog
post.
Just the durability of the signal seems to
wane so quickly.
Why do you now post more of your thoughts
to Twitter, say, than in longer form?
Bill Gurley: Yeah, probably because I'm old
and I don't have the concentration that I
used to have to get to the word out.
You brought up two subjects.
I'll answer the second part first, and then
we can talk about the tribal stuff.
I find Twitter just to be super fascinating
as your ability to get close to experts, leaders
in your field, like —
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent agree.
100 percent.
Bill Gurley: It's unbelievable.
More so than LinkedIn.
And there's a chance that some reply you give
to them, they might like or they might follow
you.
And now you, you've developed a mentor or
a peer partner.
It's really just shocking, amazing the amount
of information you can take out of this thing
if you use it properly.
Tim Ferriss: I'd say a third of my podcast
guests come from Twitter interactions and
then DM, which leads to —
Bill Gurley: Oh, yeah.
I mean, that's something you and I may feel
that most people don't know, but if you develop
a massive following, DM becomes this magical
place.
About half the time someone asks me if I can
help them recruit someone, that person follows
me.
Now I can just start talking to them right
out of the gate.
Tim Ferriss: There's a protection too for
high profile people in DM because there's
no personal information that is exchanged
and they can always block you if they get
sick of you.
And therein lies the safety.
You can also, if you're trying to interact,
and I don't do it that much, but interact
with say a-list celebrities.
Well, it's like, okay, you can try to wade
through this phalanx of agents and managers
and publicists and just take two years to
try to get a message to someone.
Or you can just DM them if that gate is open.
Bill Gurley: There's a book idea that I'm
working on, and one of my core beliefs is
that in this day and age circa 2023, your
ability to rise up in any industry or any
particular endeavor is so much easier than
it ever was before because your ability to
get close to the mentors, leaders, best practitioners,
and learn from them is unlike it's ever, ever
been before.
And add in hybrid work, maybe you can work
for a company that's not even near you.
It's really awesome for people that want to
pull themselves up.
On the tribal thing, yeah.
Look, there's a lot of you and Haidt went
deep on this and he's way smarter on it than
me, but it does reinforce performance and
yeah, it's too bad.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Let's double-click on performance.
Recent conversation with James Clear, and
I'm going to paraphrase what he said, "Who
you are and the decisions you make are downstream
of the information you consume in a sense.
So you should choose your sources of information
very carefully."
And I would tend to agree with that.
I'm pretty selective.
Are there any newsletters you subscribe to
or read regularly or writers you follow regularly?
Not in book form, but in more regular form.
Frequent form.
Bill Gurley: Eric Newcomer does a venture
capital Substack.
And so just being in the industry, that's
something to follow.
There's a website called Techmeme where Gabe
has this curated news rank, including Twitter
comments people have made about that article.
It's just, it's a daily —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's cool.
I haven't seen that integrated.
That's very cool.
Bill Gurley: Oh, yeah, it's great.
Tim Ferriss: Gabe's a machine.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, it's really well done.
In the industry, I go there.
Between Techmeme and Twitter, I end up on
a lot of Substacks and whatnot, but I don't
have one where I read every single thing they
post.
Everything's been inverted into this consumption
world where the aggregator of Twitter or Techmeme
is kind of funneling what I find and then
I go do those things.
One of the things I think Twitter should do
is define a long-form bucket container, a
podcast container and a video container, and
then have pocket like features where if you
see something like that, you store it and
then it cues the way — I mean, that's one
of the benefits of Spotify as a podcast listener,
I think it cues and organizes easier than
some of the others.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's see.
I'm just going to ask if there's anything
more you want to say about the book or do
you want to keep that under wraps largely
for now?
Is there anything else you'd like to say about
the work in progress?
Bill Gurley: Yeah, there's a speech I gave
at the University of Texas that you could
put in the show notes because it's out there
and it's talking about chasing your dream
job and how to succeed and thrive at your
dream job.
And I've done some research since I gave the
speech because people have encouraged me to
turn it into a book.
And some of the polling we've done show 70
percent of people have career regret.
70 percent, which is a huge number.
And so we're doing some more work to better
understand that and how people end up in that
place.
But the punchline, which I hinted at earlier
is I just don't think there's ever been a
better time to have a self-determined job
process if you want.
And the tools are better than they've ever
been.
And I, there's way more detail in this thing,
but it was built off of studying the biography
of a very unusual set of people, Bobby Knight,
Bob Dylan, and Danny Meyer, the restaurateur,
and seeing similar patterns in how they attacked
what they did.
Tim Ferriss: Just out of curiosity, if you
were invited to give and agreed to give a
TED Talk, but you couldn't give it on venture
capital, couldn't do investing, couldn't do
career advice, what might you give your TED
Talk on?
Bill Gurley: Probably regulatory capture.
I have this core belief that capitalism and
democracy will eventually destroy one another.
Tim Ferriss: Could you also just define regulatory
capture at some point?
You don't have to do it right now.
Bill Gurley: I do.
I mean, there's a Wikipedia entry for it.
Tim Ferriss: Just the basics for folks.
Bill Gurley: There's a famous professor from
Chicago, and I forget his name, like 1958,
that wrote the seminal report.
But basically in a heavily regulated industry,
the incumbents typically end up being the
ones that write the legislation and typically
lock themselves in.
Build competitive advantage, build a moat
back to Michael Porter through the use of
legislation, and make it harder for startups
to break in.
One of my favorite examples, the Obama administration
came up with this program where they spent
44 billion dollars paying doctors to implement
EHR systems.
And the idea that you would pay someone to
implement software when you need to do it
on your own for your own competitive survival
— but there was a healthcare advisory board,
the CEO of Epic sat on that board and they
came up with this program.
Tim Ferriss: What is Epic?
Bill Gurley: It's the leading provider of
software.
Tim Ferriss: Bingo.
Bill Gurley: Yeah, exactly.
Then, once they came up with this program,
the thing that you would obviously think is,
well, what's wrong with paying someone to
use software?
Well, they probably won't use it.
Then they put up another 20 billion for the
second phase called meaningful use where if
you proved you were using the software, you
got paid to implement, you get another check.
It's mind numbing, and this stuff is everywhere
in our government, like I said, both sides
of the aisle.
Everywhere.
And Citizens United did not help.
It made it way worse.
Our government would be way better if you
could somehow extract these powers from the
government.
Tim Ferriss: If you could wave a magic wand
and get some things moving to act as some
countervailing force to reduce regulatory
capture, what would you do?
What's the action?
Bill Gurley: By the way, we have really broken
industries with the most regulated pharma,
banks, telcos, these are the ones.
I mean, look at the banks.
Five other industrialized nations have moved
to insta transfer run by the government between
banks.
In the UK, it's called UK Faster Payments.
It happened 17 years ago.
You can read the Wikipedia page on it.
ACH in America still takes three days to clear.
It's fucking ridiculous.
But it's because the banks and Visa have too
much power with the financial services committee,
and they've prevented —
Powell wants to do it.
It's called FedNow.
It's been on the books for 10 years, but they
block it because of how we operate.
The first thing you would do, and no one will
agree to it, is you reverse Citizens United.
There's too much money in the system.
You can go to Open Secrets, I think it is,
on almost any one of these decisions and you'll
see someone — you can just watch the financial
service committee.
Someone argues against FedNow and then you
look them up and there's a big bank in their
region, and that big bank's the donor.
It's not rocket science, but that's where
I would start with some kind of reform.
One of my first experiences, this would be
definitely be in my TED Talk.
When one of my first companies I worked on
that had a potential regulatory hurdle, a
lawyer told me, "Oh, well, you should talk
to these congressmen or whatever.
Did you want me to introduce you?"
"Sure."
Get a phone call.
"He's going to be in your neighborhood.
Can you get a bunch of people in a conference
room?"
I'm like, "What do you mean a bunch of people?
I just wanted to say hello."
"No, I need you to get 15 people in the conference
room."
I go, "Why?"
He goes, "And they all need to bring the maximum
check that they can donate."
And I'm like, "Really?"
I call a few people, I felt horrible.
"Oh, yeah.
You've got to give 10 grand.
I just want to talk to this guy."
And then a week before they show up, they
go, "Your spouse can give, too.
Tell everyone their spouse can give."
This happened to me three times.
Three times.
To me, someone in Washington —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, so dirty.
So dirty.
Bill Gurley: You need to get 100 grand together
just to —
Tim Ferriss: Pay to play.
Bill Gurley: get that first meeting.
And that that's real.
That's how —
Tim Ferriss: That's a great speaking fee.
Bill Gurley: Yeah.
No, that's how it works.
And so I don't know.
You look at things like the healthcare system,
they're just so messed up.
It's not a free market and it's not single
payer, it's the worst of both, and it's the
best of from neither.
Tim Ferriss: If democracy and capitalism are
on the annihilation crash course, I mean,
what do you think, and I know this is — look,
we're talking about very complex systems and
all sorts of tertiary effects to who the hell
knows.
But what do you think the US looks like in
10 or 20 years?
Bill Gurley: Well, I'll tell you —
Tim Ferriss: And conversely, are there any
countries that you would be really long on?
Bill Gurley: That's where I go.
I mean, despite their current situation that
some people hold them against.
I think the UK, which is much older than us,
has done a better job than we have.
One thing they have —
Tim Ferriss: With what?
Just for clarity, what have they done a better
job with?
Bill Gurley: I think less regulatory capture.
And one particular thing they have that is
super clever and will cause every lawyer in
the world to hate me, they have something
called losing party pays.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yes, absolutely.
I'm astonished that the US functions the way
it does, but yeah, please continue.
Bill Gurley: And so we live in the United
States of litigation, and a lot of the friction
that exists that slows down the gears and
messes things up is because of the vigilante
nature of our legal system.
And losing party pays just makes the number
of initial litigations filed, dropped by 10X.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, losing party pays.
Yeah.
Does the UK allow its barristers to have contingency
fees or they must have some type of upper
limit on that, that is much lower than the
US.
Bill Gurley: I don’t know.
Before I give my TED Talk, I'll go a little
deeper.
Tim Ferriss: All right, regulatory capture.
Bill, is there anything else you'd like to
say?
Any closing comments, recommendations, anything
you'd like to point my audience to or ask
them to do?
Anything that comes to mind at all that you'd
like to mention before we wind to a close?
Bill Gurley: I think I'm good, man.
I think we hit on a lot of different things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, we did.
We covered a lot.
And thank you for the time, Bill.
I really appreciate it.
Bill Gurley: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: This was great.
And for everybody listening, we will put together
extensive show notes linking to everything
we talked about, and you can find that as
usual at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a bit kinder
than as necessary.
And experiment, experiment, experiment.
Thanks for tuning in.